souhaite une dose de rappel contre la
covid et une autre contre la grippe
saisonnière la vacation contre la grippe
c'est une bonne idée on sait que c'est
un grand défi cette saison 6 le Premier
ministre veut donner l'exemple pour
tenter peut-être de limiter les dégâts
dans le secteur de la santé
c'est qu'après la covid une véritable
collection de virus frappe la population
habituellement c'est
le témoin un après l'autre mais là ils
ont décidé de tous courir en même temps
donc on a du VRS on commence à avoir de
l'influenceur on a du par influenzel
un cocktail potentiellement explosif
assez pour que le Cius du nord de l'île
de Montréal déplace les équipes de
vaccination près du domicile des plus
vulnérables
va revenir probablement plus forte que
les autres années c'est d'emblée pour
protéger les gens pour éviter les
complications pour éviter les
hospitalisations reliées à ça les
urgences vivent des débordements sans
précédent alors que la grippe
saisonnière frappe un mois plus tôt qu'à
l'habitude
reçoit le vaccin contre la grippe pour
la première fois rendu à 86 ans ça
m'agace plus qu'à 30 ans
c'est ça
environ 40% des personnes âgées ont été
vaccinés ce n'est que la moitié de
l'objectif final au Québec j'ai changé
d'idées des fois trois fois ah oui et
puis là j'ai décidé de le faire une
bonne idée selon les autorités les
années et les enfants sont plus
vulnérables face à la souche dominante
de la grippe cette année avec les
masques et la distanciation l'immunité
collective va diminuer pendant la
pandémie notre immunité a pas été
stimulée ce qui fait que nos anticorps
sont pas présents alors quand on
rencontre le virus mais on est infectés
ici David gentil les radios Canada
Montréal